- I don't think I'm
better than anyone else,
I just think I'm like funnier
and that my pussy's magic.
Hi, agents?
I just got a deal?
(rock music)
- We started 27 days
ago, and in this minute
we just picture
wrapped, it's a picture.
(applause)
That was a wrap, everybody.
(cheering)
- Thank you everybody
for being so good
at your jobs and
for laughing and for
helping me make my
dreams come true
and I really appreciate
all of you guys.
(applause)
- [Curtis] And now
we drink, everybody!
(rock music)
- Comedy Central
gave me a TV show.
- [DJ] Comedy
Central gave you one?
You're gonna be fucking rich!
- I know, I know.
- [DJ] It's so awesome, are
you gonna get a shiny car?
- I'm gonna get a new bike.
This show is everything
from inside me for real.
I am a standup comedian,
so we were like
let's have standup on the show.
I really like
talking to strangers
on the street, so
man on the street.
Are you high?
- Yeah hell yeah.
- And a lot of people don't
know me as an actress.
I hope that the
next time you watch
an episode of
Homeland that the DVR
cuts out before you see
scenes from the next week
so to find out what happened you
have to just like ask
around the office,
or look online like
a homeless person!
- She's funny, she's
honest, she's edgy.
She's easy on the eyes.
And all of those things could
have been said
about Lenny Bruce.
- A little about me, I took
plan B about 10 days ago.
- People are fucking
filthy and dirty,
and women don't
really need to like
pretend that
they're not anymore.
- Do you know what HPV is?
You will, it's this fun
party disease, guys!
People are like who
brought the HPV?
I'm like this girl!
(audience laughs)
I need to have a new hour in
three months, which
is ridiculous.
- She's so quick with new
material it's unbelievable.
She does a new hour
like it's nothing,
just forms jokes it's crazy.
I'm in awe.
- I'm working on the
standup that will
be on the TV show.
A lot of it's kind of brand new.
Look at him walking to
the bathroom right now.
Look at him walking
to the bathroom right
now, that's funny.
I'm like look at him
walking to the bathroom,
like no one's going steady.
He's like ah!
It's overwhelming.
I'm working on the TV show,
I'm working on standup,
and I'm working on um...
Sign language.
Stop cutting off my great jokes!
I need to seriously
get my shit together.
Guys get whiskey dick, they
don't think we get that.
We do, we get whiskey
clit for sure!
(audience laughs)
Is whiskey clit gross?
- Amy has a way of
being very dirty
and also very vulnerable that is
actually quite
fuckable, and funny.
She would prefer that I
say fuckable than funny.
All women would.
- I'm getting ready to
headline Gotham Comedy Club.
I'm really excited
because tonight
my sister Kim is
coming into town.
- I'm sorry it's like
really loud here.
Just some bullshit,
don't worry about it.
- Did you make it into the
showroom to watch my set or?
- What tonight?
- [Amy] Her job is gonna
be to talk to the fans,
tell them about my new show.
- Will you watch her new show?
- Absolutely.
- What if there's
like other stuff
going on though
for you that night?
(rock music)
- The goal of this
is to get people
excited about the show.
(rock music)
- [Man] Amy Schumer,
let her hear it!
- Two of you, two of
us, I'll do the math.
- It's like total pussy power.
- What is this, water?
It's like Cinderella, but
I'm shaped like a pumpkin.
Look at my nails, like am I
really supposed to be a woman?
Las Vegas!
Vegas knows how to fuck
you in the ass, what?
- Ta-Dah.
(rock music)
- Writing on the TV show?
Honestly, it's going amazing.
- Amy runs the show
much like a Jim Jones
style Guyanese cult,
and we're all gonna die.
- Going into the office is fun.
It's just a group
of dirty comedians
morally bankrupt,
horrible people
and it's so fun,
we just sit around
and see who's the worst person.
But it's usually me.
(rock music)